People ask what the meaning of life is
and it seems to me that meaning is
proportionate to the adoption of
responsibility.
You know,
like let's say you have a little sister
who's like three,
you're going to take care of her.
Like questioning whether that's a good
idea just seemed stupid.
You know what I mean?
It just doesn't seem like the right kind
of question.
It's like,
well obviously self evidently let's say
that's what you do and you find it
meaningful.
It's like probably,
you know,
interacting with a little kid when we
had,
when I had little kids,
you know,
when they were like two or under,
we took them out to see their relatives
and they were older people and you know,
they watched that two year old like,
like it was a fire,
you know,
every second that that little kid was in
the room,
every single adult was focused on,
focused on,
on him or her.
Yeah.
That's something that people attended to
and that's a source of meaning.
And what else is a meaningful?
Well,
your family relationships are meaningful
to you and maybe the responsibility that
you adopt as,
as a friend that,
that seems meaningful.
Maybe your decision to pursue a
particular career and be of some utility
in society,
you know,
part of that's governed by your desire
to establish some security and get
ahead.
It's fine,
but you're also playing an integral role
in the maintenance of the structure that
supports you.
And my observation has been that in my
clinical practice is that people just
have a hell of a time if they don't
have,
if they don't slot in somewhere,
you know,
you think I got to go to work at nine in
the morning and you know,
I've got this rigid schedule.
It's like
it's probably a good idea to be grateful
for that because of.
What I have noticed is that if people
pull out from those externally
scaffolded systems,
they drift,
they get depressed,
they get anxious,
they don't know what to do with
themselves.
You know,
they're kinda like sled dogs with no
slab and we're kinda like sled dogs as
far as I can tell.
Beasts of burden.
Like we need a load,
man,
we need a load,
and the question is what,
what sort of low do you need?
And here's why I think we need,
we need that.
You know,
there's,
I've been thinking about how to figure
out what's real for a long time and
because I'm an existentialist,
I'm operating under the presupposition
that you can tell what people believe by
watching what they,
how they act.
I don't care what they say,
I don't care what their statements are
about their view of reality because the
correlation,
the relationship between that and their
actual actions is not certainly not
perfect and sometimes it doesn't even
exist.
One thing I've noticed is that people,
no one argues with their own pain.
Everyone who hurts acts as if they
believe that pain is real.
So we could say the ultimate reality is
pain.
That's how people act.
It's in keeping with the claims of many
religious traditions.
You know,
the Jews are always recollecting past
pain.
I mean the Christian God is crucified
person.
I mean there's a fair bit of pain there
for the Buddhists.
The fundamental maximum is that life is
suffering.
And I'm,
it seems to me that there's a
metaphysical claim there no metaphysical
claim is that pain is real.
Now,
of course it depends on what you mean by
real,
but people act as if their pain is real.
So that's a good place to start.
Now that poses a problem.
Life is a pain,
life is suffering,
let's say.
And why is that?
Well,
it's because you can be broken,
hurt and destroyed.
And so that seems pretty self evident
and worse,
you know it.
And that makes people unique.
Like that's our selfconsciousness,
right?
That's really what separates us in some
sense from other creatures.
I mean other creatures have some self
consciousness like a chimp can learn to
recognize itself and a mirror and
soaking a dolphin.
But you know,
that's pretty,
that's pretty bare bones,
selfconsciousness,
you know,
real self consciousness is the knowledge
of your borders and not only in space
but in time.
And as far as I can tell,
human beings are the only creatures that
have discovered the future.
And that's really good because we can
plan for the future,
but it's really bad because you know the
future is finite and that's like that's
a big shock to the old system and it's
the existential burden that everyone
bears and its associated integrity with
suffering.
And so then you think,
well,
life is suffering and it's finite and
that's part of the suffering.
That's part of what you makes you
question the value of existing and maybe
the value of existence itself.
So then what do you have to,
were used as a weapon against that?
Well,
you know,
we talked a little bit about
responsibility.
Now it seems to work,
you know,
the,
the amount of responsibility that you
adopt
with really in relationship to things
seems to increase your meaningful
engagement.
And you might say,
well what's the most meaningfully
engaged activity?
And you might say,
well how about little reduction in the
old suffering?
No.
So you live your life so that you're not
causing undue pain,
especially pointless pain.
That would be good.
And maybe you could even be more useful
than that.
And you could figure out some ways that
some suffering years,
other people's both,
if you're really hitting a home run,
maybe you can figure out some way that
some of that can be rectified and that
seems to be meaningful in and of itself.
I mean,
if it's pain that makes you doubt the
meaning of life,
which is perfectly reasonable,
then the cessation of pain,
the cessation of suffering,
the minimization of suffering as a
logical corollary should be the proper
medication.
And so I would say that means that
there's some mode that you can conduct
yourself in that makes you a good person
and
part of being a good person is to
alleviate suffering.
And
I don't think you get to question that
actually.
If,
if the suffering itself is what's making
you question the validity of your life,
then you can't also say that the
cessation of that is not useful.
I mean you can,
but it's completely incoherent.
You can.
You can claim incoherent things if you
want.
So then I would say these distilled
stories that I'm talking about,
the stories that are written by great
authors,
I'm particularly fond of Dostoevsky
whose,
whose works are he's head and shoulders
above anyone I've ever read in terms of
writers of fiction.
He deals with the hardest questions that
human beings face and he,
he has characters on both sides of the
argument and there they really lay out
the arguments.
It's not like Dostoevsky and all.
He has got a belief and so he has a
character and that character has his
beliefs.
And that character always wins the
arguments.
It's that doesn't happen.
And the Dostoyevsky novel at all,
he sets up a character and then he sets
up like three or four antagonists and
those antagonists,
they're not straw men,
they're like iron giants.
They just stomp his,
his protagonist,
you know.
And the whole thing is a war between
these different conceptions of being.
It's amazing to see.
It's amazing to read.
Um,
so you distill these stories,
great authors distill stories,
great storytellers distill stories,
and we have stories that are very,
very,
very old.
Those are usually religious stories.
Of one form or another particular be
fairy tales because fairy tales,
some people have traced fairytales back,
you know,
more than 10,000
years and so they're part of an oral
tradition and oral traditions can last
for tens of thousands of years and you
know,
it's a story that's been told for 10,000
years is a funny kind of story.
It's like people have remembered it and,
and obviously modified it.
It's like the game of telephone,
you know,
where I tell you something and you
whispered to the person next to you and
so on.
It's like a game of telephone that's
gone on for you know,
thousand generations and all that's left
is what people remember and maybe they
remember what's important because you
tend to remember what's important and
didn't necessarily the case that you
know,
what the hell it means.
You don't know what music means,
but you know that's a stop you from
listening to it.
You don't know.
Generally speaking,
what a movie that you see or a book that
you read means not.
If it's profound,
it means more than you can understand
because otherwise why read it.